اربعه مرشحين رسميا في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه المقرره في الرابعه عشر
من مايو المقبل الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان وابرز خصومه السياسيين رئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كمالك ورئيس حزب البلد
محرم جاه ومرشح تحالف الاجداد سنانوغان
درسنا كل الاعتراضات التي وصلتنا وفق مواد
دستوري وقوانين الجمهوريه ونتيجه لذلك
وباجماع الاصوات فان القائمه النهائيه
للمرشحين ستضم كمالك الاجداوغلو ومحرم جاء
ورجب طيب اردوغان وسنان اوغان
نجاح انجي واوغان في الوصول الى السباق
الرئاسي يعني حصولهما على نسبه من اصوات
الناخبين ما يزيد من ضبابيه صوره المنافسه
الرئاسيه
امام الرئيس اردوغان في انتخابات 2018
وحصل حينها على اكثر من 30% من الاصوات ما
يزيد احتمال ان تذهب الانتخابات الى جوله
ثانيه في حال انتهج اداء جيدا في الايام
المقبله ينتهج اردوغان في حملته
الانتخابيه نمطا ساكنا بعيدا عن الاناشيد
والاحتفالات بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
ويعد باعاده بناء مئات الالاف من الوحدات
السكنيه ويقدم وعودا اخرى اما زعيم تحالف
المعارضه كمال كليتشار اولو فيعد بتحسين
وضع البلاد وتخليصها مما تسميها المعارضه
سلطه الرجل الواحد ويعد انجا بضمان حريه
الاعلام واستقلاليه القضاء وتحسين الوضع
الاقتصادي وتمثل اعاده من هم تحت الحمايه
المؤقته واللاجئين والمهاجرين غير
الشرعيين الى بلادهم البند الابرز على
اجنده المرشح اوغان
في السنوات الاخيره تحاول اردوغان الى
شخصيه مؤثره دوليا اضافه الى سجله الداخلي
في حين يركز المرشحون الثلاثه الاخرون على
الوضع الداخلي
المحفظه تشير قائمه المرشحين الاربعه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه الى ان المنافسه على
منصب الرئيس ستكون صعبه وقد اعلن المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات انه في حال لم يحسم اسم
الرئيس يوم الانتخاب فان جوله للاعاده
ستجرى بعده باسبوعين بين المرشحين
الحاصلين على اعلى الاصوات المعتز بالله
حسن الجزيره انقره